♪♪
Narrator:
A CRAFTSMAN PREPARES TO CARVE.
HE STARTS BY USING
A MASONRY COMPASS
AND A LIQUID CALLED CHINESE INK
TO DRAW THE MORTAR'S
INNER AND OUTER CIRCUMFERENCE.
HE CAN EASILY REMOVE THE INK
IF THERE ARE ANY ERRORS.
HE ROUGHS OUT THE SHAPE
WITH A HAMMER AND CHISEL.
HE THEN WORKS WITH A GRINDER
WHICH IS EQUIPPED
WITH AN EXTREMELY HARD
DIAMOND-TIPPED BLADE,
MAKING IT POSSIBLE
TO CUT THROUGH SOLID STONE.
ONCE'S HE'S DEFINED
THE OUTSIDE EDGE,
HE BEGINS TO WORK
THE INNER BOWL,
CARVING OUT THE PERIMETER
BEFORE CUTTING A GRID.
HE TURNS AGAIN
TO HIS HAMMERS AND CHISELS
TO REMOVE MATERIAL
FROM THE INSIDE OF THE MORTAR.
WITH THE GRINDER, HE WORKS AWAY
AT ALL OF THE SURFACES,
SMOOTHING THEM
TO A CONSISTENT FINISH.
A MORTAR ISN'T MUCH GOOD
WITHOUT A PESTLE.
ONCE AGAIN WORKING WITH
THE CONFIDENT SWIFTNESS
OF AN EXPERT,
THE ARTISAN USES HIS GRINDER
TO HONE A CHUNK OF GRANITE
DOWN TO THE SHAPE
OF A WELL-BALANCED PESTLE.
WIDE AND BLUNT ON ONE END
AND NARROW ENOUGH
TO EASILY GRASP ON THE OTHER,
THE STONE IS PERFECTLY
CALIBRATED TO DO ITS JOB.
IN THE DAYS BEFORE POWER TOOLS,
IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN
A CRAFTSMAN A FULL DAY
TO CARVE A MORTAR AND PESTLE.
BUT A CARVED MORTAR AND PESTLE
ISN'T NECESSARILY
A FINISHED ONE.
HERE, A PAINTER
ADDS THE FINAL TOUCHES.
USING A SMALL BRUSH
AND SPECIAL VARNISH,
HE PAINTS A LOTUS FLOWER DESIGN
ON THE LIP OF THE MORTAR.
HE LEAVES THE BOWL ITSELF
UNTOUCHED
SO THAT NO FOOD PRODUCTS
WILL MIX WITH THE VARNISH
WHEN CRUSHED.
HE THEN VARNISHES THE EXTERIOR
OF THE MORTAR.
THE VARNISHING PROCESS
IS PURELY DECORATIVE.
HARD STONE LIKE GRANITE
NEEDS NO PROTECTIVE COATING
TO HELP IT ENDURE.
AFTER ALL, SOME GRANITE HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR MILLIONS OF YEARS.
IT TAKES JUST 15 TO 20 MINUTES
FOR THE VARNISH TO DRY.
AND WITH THAT, THE MORTAR
IS COMPLETELY FINISHED.
THE LOTUS FLOWER DESIGN
ISN'T THE ONLY ONE AVAILABLE.
THIS FACILITY
PRODUCES A WIDE RANGE
OF MORTARS AND PESTLES.
THESE MORTARS AND PESTLES
MAY BE ATTRACTIVE.
BUT THEIR APPEARANCE
IS SECONDARY TO THEIR FUNCTION.
THERE ARE FEW TOOLS IN A KITCHEN
MORE DURABLE OR MORE USEFUL
THAN A GOOD MORTAR AND PESTLE.